hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website comm and today we're going
to be looking at the cour con defense
which is one of the most popular
defenses against whites King pawn
opening and it starts out with pawn to
e4 and black playing pawn to c6 and
basically the idea behind this is he's
looking to on the next move plays pawn
to d5 and undermine this pawn on e4 but
he wants to have support here from this
pawn on c6 he would really like to have
both his pawns on e and V and give up
his pawn on c6 but it really depends on
how white plays from here we're going to
go over the main line which is the
classical variation then we're going to
go over some of the less common
variations that you will see because
there are quite a few different
variations in the Cara con but the main
line we're just going to kind of talk
about some of the key concepts in the
main line but it starts out with pawn to
d4 many times you just see why continue
pushing up the board trying to gain
Center control with his pawns very
common theme in opening principles and
White's going give me blacks going to
push forward with his pawn to d5
attacking this pawn and from here
White's going to continue with his
knight on c3 attacking our pawn on d5
and at the same time putting a defender
on his pawn on e4 now obviously white
could take on d5 and we'll go over that
variation and not too long here but the
main line continues with 90 to c3 and
black is going to take on e4 and then
white is going to recapture on e4 from
here black is going to develop his
Bishop eventually black is going to
bring his pawn to e6 and cut work on a
lot of times we'll turn into a French
defense if it's not the main line but in
the main line you're going to see a car
con player have his pawn here on c6
you're gonna have his pawn here on e6
he'd really like to have his bishop out
his LightSquared Bishop out before he
plays e6 obviously he doesn't want to
block it in
then he's going to bring his Knight to
d7 many times giving support to his
knight that's usually going to be on f6
here then he can always bring his queen
to c7 very nice place here he has a lot
of sinner control and his dark square
bishop once the e6 has been played can
roam around the board he can Castle
kingside
opening this is going to be very good
for black this is actually one of the
few openings that you'll see where the
mainline black can actually reach
neutrality and in the same time a lot of
people think that black has a better
game especially in the in game where it
comes down to pawn structure life is
actually going to have a better pawn
structure and then white does and we'll
get into that here in a minute play here
continues in the main line with black
moving his knight to g3 obviously we
were attacking it on e4 with our bishop
here and he is now attacking our bishop
so we are going to bring it back to g6
no reason to overextend it yet we don't
have any other pieces out to support
that bishop so we're just going to bring
it back it still has a long diagonal
attacking this c2 square but it's on a
long diagonal right now which is
completely fun and here the main line is
white plays h4 which in the in game is
actually going to hurt his pawn
structure but in the main line it does
start to come down the board and attack
us and get this Bishop which is actually
a very good Bishop for us on the light
square out of the way so we're going to
go ahead and move pawn to h6 in the main
line giving our bishop a layout if he
does continue at the board obviously he
has his knight here on G 3 supporting if
he does push forward that way we can
kick our bishop back to h7 main line
continues with the development of the
night and then we're going to bring our
Knight to d7 we're eventually going to
bring our knight to f6 and this is
merely supporting that and at the same
time it's giving us a little more
central control in a good development
Square now we can bring our Queen into
the action
and we can choose the Castle queenside
or kingside we have a lot of different
options in the car Khan White's going to
continue to push forward with h5 and
we're going to go and kick our Bishop
back to h7 and now since our Bishop is
very good on this diagonal here White's
going to exchange bishops so we're going
to go on exchanges really no other place
for us to move we're not going to try
anything risky by moving a pawn we're
just going to go ahead and exchange
there we don't want to move our rook yet
we could obviously let the bishop come
down and capture them and capture with
our roof but then we can't Castle
kingside and we want that to be an
option even if we don't choose that
route so after the Queen captures we're
going to move ecigs
go development move opens up a line for
our Queen on the dock squares our Queen
can choose you decide to go to and our
bishop now is activating we can move it
along these dark squares which is very
good for us and from here this is the
common thing in the mainline we're
eventually going to bring our knight to
f6 we can bring our bishop into the
action if we want to extend it farther
if we just want to bring it to score
like eise evan more than likely you'll
get it involved into the action again
you can Castle kingside you can bring
your Queen into the action by b6
attacking the b2 square or you can just
bring it to b7 eyeing down on the King
side of them you can Castle queenside it
really depends up to you but as you can
see there's a lot of play that black has
from comicon especially in the mainline
and if you look at our pawn scripture
it's very good right now we have four on
one side three on the other we really
haven't deviated from
any over extension of our ponds like
White has with this move down to h5 so
that's the main line we're going to take
a look at some of the other variations
that you will see the other variation
that you will see is this MS la
variation which is Pawnee 4 c 6 d 4 D 5
and when he brings his Knight to c3 and
we recapture then we bring our Knight to
d7 and the goal of this is to eventually
bring our Knight to f6 and once we
exchanged Knights then our B Knight our
Queen side Knight will be on f6 and then
we can open up our bishop here now white
can have a lot of play here if you just
play something like Knight to g5 and
this is actually what Kasparov lost to
when he played the con defense against
deep blue there's just a lot of traps
that you can fall into why it's not
going to allow black to exchange the
Knights here and so I feel like it's a
trickier position to play as black and I
usually don't recommend it to people
when they're learning the ComicCon but
it is good to know about if you do see
it another thing you may see and the
ComicCon starts out before we'll go over
some more variations here c6 d4 pawn d5
then he brings his Knight to c3 and
capture and recapture one things you may
see here is Knight to f6 and then when
recaptures there's two variations
there's a Bronstein Larson which is
simply pawn captures on f6 which the
goal of this is to give an open file to
the rook yeah it does give an open file
to the rook but it does kind of
undermine our pawn structure here it's
going to be real tough for us to Castle
kingside we're more than likely not
going to Castle kingside we want to keep
this open file for our route but in the
in game our pawn structure is not quite
going to be as good as wide as you can
see we have three pawn islands here it's
going to be a little harder for us other
variation you may see in this is
you may see pawn capture on f6 which I
feel is a little bit better
you can still Castle kingside and get a
lot of play but those are two of the
things you may see now another variation
that you will see is the advanced
variation starts out the same
efore c 6d 5d 4d 5 but instead of now
playing Knight to c3 white may simply
play pawn to e5 now from here black has
two options the first one is bringing
his Bishop to f5 where the knight can
now come to c3 and after we develop with
pawn to e6 very common move after we
bring our Bishop out to move pawn to e6
then Y can play pawn to g4 putting a lot
of pressure on our Bishop and we're
going to have to kick our Bishop back
out this is one thing you may see white
excuse me black does have another option
here if he doesn't want to play
f5 he can play c5 and from here if he
white chooses to take then we can play
e6 and it kind of takes on a French
defense here so we are giving up
material but we're looking to get it
back later on if you're familiar with
the French defense you'll definitely
want to take a look at this variation
it's something that you may see quite
often another variation that you may see
quite often if someone's not too
familiar with the main line is after c6
d4 and d5 it's not as common but you may
see white take on d5 and from here we
can take on d5 with our pawn this is
going to be completely fine with this
there's a lot of things that white can
do but as you can tell already we have
both of our Center pawns and white only
has one of the center pawns we can
simply bring our knight into action with
c6 putting a lot of pressure on the
center I feel like this is actually a
better position for black as we still
have both of our Center pawns and we can
develop like normal White's missing his
epon here and I feel like he's better
off playing c3 instead of taking in the
exchange variation so if you see this
this is actually very good for black you
can set
you can develop like normal and you're
going to have a very good game so these
are some of the common things you'll see
in the CARICOM hope you guys enjoyed if
you haven't already please subscribe and
I'll see you guys next video thanks for
watching